mais d'abord cette nouvelle union
populaire écologiques et sociales qui
intègre les socialistes tous les
socialistes ça c'est une autre histoire
qui commence samia de chiens sourire aux
lèvres ils viennent d'annoncer la
nouvelle à la presse après des heures de
négociations un accord a été trouvé
entre un sommier socialiste c'était la
dernière pièce manquante pour une grande
coalition de gauche aux législatives aux
côtés de la france en soumises des
écologistes et des communistes
aujourd'hui cette mission de regrouper
le bloc populaire elle est faite et nous
en sommes très heureuses et est très
heureux elle est faite sur un programme
d'abord un programme de rupture puisque
l'ensemble des composantes politiques
qui se regroupent dans cette nouvelle
union populaire le fond autour de
d'orientation programmatique qui sont
partagés les socialistes ont obtenu 70
circonscription pour investir leurs
candidats dont une petite trentaine sont
gagnables l'accord doit maintenant être
approuvée par le conseil national du
parti socialiste nous proposeront demain
cet accord qui reprend et qui a permis à
chacune et à chacun d'entre nous de
faire les pas nécessaires d'avoir son
identité est respectée tant sur le fond
que sur l'implantation territoriale je
crois que aujourd'hui nous sommes à
quelques heures d'un moment historique
d'un historique attendu depuis des
années par le peuple de gauche qui vous
demandez qui nous demandaient ardemment
de savoir nous rassembler si les parties
se sont entendues facilement sur la
retraite à 60 ans ou l'augmentation du
smic à 1400 euros d'autres points de
blocage ont dû être levés notamment sur
la désobéissance aux règles européennes
il a donc fallu peser chaque mot du
communiqué publié cet après midi du fait
de nos histoires nous parlons de
désobéir pour les interroger de manière
transitoire pour les autres il faudra
dépasser ses blocages et est prêt à ne
pas respecter certaines règles
tout en travaillant les transformer en
particulier les règles économiques
sociales et budgétaires le feu vert du
conseil national n'est pas totalement
garanti certains ténors menace de
quitter le parti en opposition totale
avec l'accord négocié par la jeune
génération
gilles partie d'une génération qui a qui
a vu la fin du quinquennat de hollande
est dit j'ai envie de vous dire dix ans
après donc de 2012 à 2022 j'ai vu plutôt
un parti qui a subi de beaucoup plus de
défaites que de victoires en réalité et
un effondrement à la fois dans sa base
militante et
dans ces élus et donc du coup je me
rends compte que il faut passer par des
choses parfois douloureuses faut se
faire faut se faire mal parfois pour
reconstruire le conseil national du
parti socialiste se réunira demain pour
examiner l'accord s'il est approuvé la
gauche aura réussi en quelques jours
l'union qu'elle n'a pas su trouver pour
la présidentielle
bienvenue dans les cuisines électorales
de ces législatives lal thème de notre
débat et je vous présente mes invités
nathalie morel bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes jarvis politique pour le
groupe ebra les dernières nouvelles
d'alsace le progrès ou encore l'est
républicain entre autres claude weil
bonsoir chroniqueur politique bienvenue
à vous sur ce plateau de sens public
jean daniel lévy bonsoir bonsoir nu vous
êtes directeur délégué d'harris
interactive matthieu croissandeau
bonsoir mathieu du temps les champions
les côtés comme
chaque mercredi chaque lundi vous serez
là aussi demain vous avez droit à un peu
de rab aller pour lancer dès ce débat je
vous propose d'écouter ceux ci
m
les plus cinéphiles d'entre vous reconnu
le tube de sonny and cher qui réveille
chaque matin bill murray dans le film un
jour sans fin vous voyez venir un jour
sans fin c'est ce que nous vivons depuis
trois jours tout cela chroniqueur
éditorialiste
sondeurs à attendre la fumée blanche au
dessus du siège de la france insoumise
ça y est le parti socialiste a dit oui
le ps a dit oui mais à quel prix voilà
ce dont on va débattre tout de suite
matelly mort et qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cet accord je pense que le
parti socialiste n'avait pas la main sur
le prix à payer puisque vous dites à
quel prix mais le score du parti
socialiste ne lui permettait pas
beaucoup de dénis négocier les prix
juste il faut se rappeler enfin avoir en
tête de chiffres la france insoumise
enfin jean luc mélenchon il a fait plus
de 12 5% des inscrits donc ce qu'il faut
le là ce qui est nécessaire pour être
deuxième tour des législatives il a fait
ce score là dans plus de 400
circonscription donc sur 577 hockey et
de l'autre côté le meilleur score de
anne hidalgo c'est 4,63 % quand vous
avez fait 600 mille voix parce que s'ils
sont finies vois ça parle encore plus
que 1 % quand vous aviez 600 mille voix
bas vous êtes vous asseyez à la table
des négociations c'est déjà bien sympa
qu'on vous laisse vous asseoir et vous
payez le prix qu'il faut le prix qu'il
faut c'est quoi c'est très très cher
c'est se renier sur beaucoup de choses
sur sur la social-démocratie clairement
aujourd'hui on affiche enfin on assiste
à un moment historique c'est l'union de
la gauche d'accord mais c'est pas
l'union de la gauche sur un espace plus
central si l'union de la gauche autour
de la france insoumise donc d'une voix
plus radicale
effectivement cette historie claude
weiss qu'olivier fort et mieux fait de
rester bloqué dans ce jour sans fin et
d'autres jamais signé cet accord
demandez à un jugement personnel
éditorialisé moi ce qui me ce qui m'a le
plus frappé comme observateur c'est le
incroyable coup de poker est peut-être
le coup de génie politique a réussi jean
luc mélenchon rappelle qu'il avait 22 %
au premier tour c'est à dire qu'il est
éliminé par au second tour et on s'est
tous les sondages démontrent qu'à peu
près la moitié de ses électeurs
n'étaient pas des électeurs insoumis
c'était des électeurs de centre gauche
ou écologistes qui ont fait barrage pour
lui pour faire barrage marine le pen
c'est à dire pour que la gauche se
présente au second tour donc y considère
que les 22 sont à lui et y réussit un
tour de 1 tour de un coup magistral
d'une certaine façon qui consiste à
s'appuyer sur l'échec historique de la
gauche 30% tout mouillé au premier tour
d'abris en ciel c'est le plus faible
score de la gauche sous la vème
république et y réussit grâce à ça à
parachever ce qui était son objectif
stratégique depuis 15 ans depuis qu'il a
quitté parti soit 10 en 2008 c'est
d'imposer son hégémonie à l'ensemble de
la gauche est de tordre le cou au parti
socialiste ce qui était pour lui
quasiment une obsession il a quitté le
parti socialiste parce qu'ils pensaient
qu'il n'y avait pas d'espoir pour la
social démocratie en france et qu'il
fallait imposer une offre alternative
révolutionnaire face à la droite d'une
certaine façon c'est la défaite de la
gauche et l'écroulement du parti
socialiste et le feq accessoirement les
équipes des écolos soit la rue aussi
compris financièrement parce qu'ils ont
tôt fait les 5% qui fait qu'ils étaient
prêts alors il ya la nature humaine
c'est vrai que le parti socialiste est
dirigé par des incapables invertébrés
mais le la nature la politique étant ce
qu'elle est des gens qui renient leurs
consultants conviction pour des sièges
ça c'est vieux que l'on ne s'est pas
fait mais deux mille ans que ça dure
rien d'extraordinaire ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est ce retournement
historique qui permet à l'extrême gauche
de prendre la main sur la sur l'ensemble
de la gauche c'est à dire non d'imposer
son hégémonie à la faveur d'une défaite
tu trouves ça qui est quelque chose
d'intéressant jean daniel lévy et
c'était une demande forte des électeurs
de gauche 7 l'union ah oui c'est une
demande de façon quelle que soit la
question qu'on pose quelles que soient
les circonstances il ya toujours une
attente d'union que ce soit de la part
des électeurs de droite à l'égard de la
formation politique que ce soit des
français salariés à l'égard des
confédérations syndicales où que ce soit
à l'égard des électeurs de gauche
concernant l'offre politique et ce
d'autant plus que on a quand même pas
tout à fait le deuil de la fête de la
gauche qui a une capacité à pouvoir
exprimer un message au niveau national
plus la question de l'union que la
question du contenu après quand on entre
dans le détail on peut voir que il ya
des points sur lesquels il peut y avoir
des désaccords profonds entre les
français ne serait-ce que ceux qui ont
voté pour anne hidalgo d'un côté et jean
luc mélenchon de doute c'est pas
exactement les mêmes les mêmes
motivations mais ya des regards des
ressorts qui peut être des ressorts à
caractère identitaire qu'ils font que
d'un côté pablo vian en tout cas pour
ces 30% de français il se dit c'est pas
possible que la gauche disparaît c'est
pas possible qu'on n'est pas encore
notre message à pouvoir exprimer par
delà le simple perrine allemand au sein
duquel on peut être amené à évoluer
c'est quelque chose qui est important et
c'est ce sur quoi a vraiment réussi à
capitaliser jean luc mélenchon dans le
cadre de cette présidentielle avec la
petite idée peut-être que on va pas
gagner la présidentielle mais quand même
le débat l'antre de deux ans elle avait
perdu en tout cas dans ce contexte là
quand il avait indiqué qu'il attendait
22 pour cent soixante dix ans peut-être
quoi pas gagné présidentielle mais au
moins le fait d'avoir un débat qui soit
un débat avec emmanuel macron ça
changera quand même la nature du pays
qui sera différent d'un débat de celui
qui pour exister avec marine le pen
mathieu dans ce coup de poker moi ce que
je retiens
aussi d'être en train d'installer l'idée
que éventuellement
tout en ayant fait 30% tout mouillé
comme vous dites la gauche pourrait
peut-être remporter législatives il ya
aussi cette petite musique m6 en deux
lots des mains en général on lui dit
comme ça mais bon quand on regarde
justement les douze ennemis % des
inscrits qui vont pouvoir avoir dans
chaque circonscription c'est compliqué
c'est en tout cas la meilleure façon d
obtenir plus que si on rassemble toute
la gauche pardon il n'y aura pas de
candidature concurrente et donc c'est le
meilleur moyen de faire un premier score
un bon score au premier tour moi ya
plusieurs choses qui me frappe c'est
d'abord que le ps c'est assez drôle
parce qu'on lui demandait depuis des
années de jeudi on sait en général
médiatique politique de clarifier sa
ligne on lui disait vous n'avez pas fait
votre bad godesberg en référence à ce
congrès allemand du spd ou le spd avait
abandonné le marxisme avait dit que
c'était plus de parti des travailleurs
mais le parti du peuple entier bref on
était plutôt sur une ligne comme ça au
ps une tentation qui était celle là et
là hop il choisi de trancher la ligne
mais absolument dans l'autre sens
l'autre chose c'est que l'union de la
gauche a s'est construite dans
l'histoire jamais en quinze jours envers
le front populaire ça s'est pas fait en
quinze jours le programme commun s'est
pas fait en quinze jours même la gauche
plurielle qui s'était faite de façon un
peu accéléré avec la dissolution avait
été quand même anticipé par des états
généraux de la transformation sociale
qui avait été menée à l'époque avec les
syndicats tout ça les concerne ce
communiqué acea ce communiqué est
improbable où il ya les deux mots pour
parler de l'horreur est déréglée roger
désobéir et c'est d'autant plus
important que le parti socialiste était
quand même un parti de débat est un
parti où les orientations se discutaient
par des votes militants à travers des
congrès et non pas au coin d'une table
avec des gens qui veulent renverser la
table et là ce qu'est ce qui est très
frappant en fait c'est vrai que les
électeurs soutiennent ça parce que il ya
le côté on va relever le drapeau de la
gauche parce que la gauche le drapeau de
la gauche il est au sol depuis la
défaite de benoît hamon un peu avant au
cours du quinquennat hollande pour tous
ceux qui en a qui en étaient déçus donc
il ya cette idée de fierté on va pas
laisser la gauche se faire laminer il
faut que ça existe mais le choix qui est
fait c'est le choix d'une gauche qui est
radical peut-être plus révolutionnaire
mais dans l'histoire de la gauche
française y avait des réformistes et les
radicaux il est ce qu'ils considéraient
qu'il fallait exercer le pouvoir qu'il
fallait passer des compromis et qu'en
pratique on pouvait changer le monde et
puis il ya ceux qui étaient dans le
discours est dans l'opposition et qui en
théorie voulais faire beaucoup mieux
beaucoup plus et donc c'est cette ligne
là qui a été choisi la dernière et c'est
une approche d'une gauche très radical
est ce que les électeurs ont le
sentiment ou est ce que le parti
socialiste a le sentiment que cette
radicalité de trouver un jour une
majorité politique ou sociologique en
france moi ça me paraît très compromis
parce que je ne vois pas une demande de
khalid et de radicalité à ce point faire
50 % plus plus une voie à la prochaine
présidentielle par exemple mais je peux
mourir complètement mais en tout cas on
est vraiment sur une rupture historique
de du choix de la gauche de 2,2
d'exister de pratiquer pouvoir et 2 et 2
et de développer ses idées nathalie
morin olivier faure il veut il veut
simplement sauver le ps c'est d'abord
une affaire financière merci ça olivier
faure et il est député mais aussi patron
du parti socialiste et donc c'est lui
qui a les mains dans le cambouis c'est
aussi un chef d'entreprise donc il doit
il avait une trentaine de députés le
parti socialiste lors de la jce la
turquie s'achève il est obligé de sauver
les meubles et d'avoir un certain nombre
de députés pour sauver les finances de
son parti c'est sa clio en train de
regarder et puis il voit aussi que il
n'a pas lu il n'y a pas le choix il a il
a twitté en tout à l'heure il ya moins
d'une heure sur sur son compte twitter
il a dit c'est en allant vers la mer que
le fleuve est fidèle à sa source c'est
une citation de jean jaurès ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on ne peut pas
aller à contre courant et que le courant
pour l'instant il est emmené par jean
luc mélenchon je suis d'accord avec
mathieu ça ne présage pas de ce qui peut
se passer dans cinq ans pour la
prochaine élection présidentielle mais
là en ce moment ils ont besoin de quoi
les socialistes qu'ils ont besoin d'un
groupe o
à l'assemblée nationale est la meilleure
façon de le faire céder effectivement
aller à l'élection législative en étant
là jamais 6 rue autant davantage ou
moins de députés en allant aux élections
sous la propre couleur je rappelle
qu'ils ont grimpé de bonnes performances
les français ont tellement disjoint les
des scrutins nationaux des scrutins
locaux que les socialistes ont eu de
très bons résultats aux élections
municipales et aux élections régionales
mais ils ont vu moins de 5% dans l'armée
mais est-ce qu'on peut projeter le
résultat de la présidentielle sur les
statiques je sais pas je vous pose la
même question à quel prix à quel prix
parce que bien sûr le fleuve fidèles
jordaniens qui étaient cruelles et que
je trouve
injustement cruel c'est le mot pablo
vient la gauche est attaché le peuple de
gauche est attaché profondément à
l'union il ya toujours eu ça fait partie
du jeu dirait delà du génotype de gauche
la nostalgie des grands moments de rock
de rassemblement de réconciliation mais
la réalité c'est pas ça la réalité c'est
que depuis dix neuvième siècle la gauche
radicale révolutionnaire et la gauche
réformiste n'ont pas cessé d'être en
consultant la concurrence et se sont
combattus extrêmement violemment le
front populaire 80 sont des pas rater
des parenthèses enchantées qui ont
enjolivé en plus par le souvenir sont
entrés dans l'histoire de la gauche
comme des moments merveilleux et ils ont
été des moments merveilleux pour les
classes populaires pour les obtenu des
avancées sociales considérables à ces
moments là est-ce que nous sommes dans
une espèce de nouveaux 36 ou nouveau 80
je crois que non là ça serait une erreur
de lecture je pense qu'une certaine
façon ce que nous vivons c'est 1,36 à
l'envers car qu'est-ce que ces 36 c'est
le monde parti communiste qui était un
parti révolutionnaire qui privilégie la
voie révolutionnaire pour l'accession au
pouvoir
le parc était totalement inféodée à
moscou accepte de rentrer dans le jeu
démocratique
derrière léon blum c'est à dire c'est la
normalisation démocratique du pc et 80
c'est le moment où le terran juché sur
les épaules et georges marchais prend le
pouvoir pour imposer un socialisme
réformiste très radicale à l'époque mais
dont il garde les rênes il n'est pas
question que mitterrand tdo fils les
rênes au parti communiste ya quatre
ministres en 80 je le répète là c'est
exactement le contraire c'est le parti
de jaurès blum mitterrand rocard delors
a ajouté qu'ils vous voulez à la liste
qui avalise cautionne le programme de la
france insoumise parce qu'en réalité le
programme le le le d'une part comme un
jeu pas non il s'appelle en réalité ces
prétendants de choses près le programme
de la france insoumise avec un peu de
rimmel sur une peau pour pour faire
vanner certains trucs mais il faut bien
voir que ce programme n'était acceptable
en effet que dans un climat de d'extrême
nécessité pourquoi parce que en réalité
on récapitule le la france la france
insoumise mais jean-luc mélenchon parce
que la france se soit hissé leur
immersion et antiaméricain
littéralement de ces américains le parti
socialiste historiquement est atlantiste
la france est soumise et anti-européenne
le parti socialiste est profondément
européen et je pourrais continuer comme
ça indéfiniment le parti socialiste me
mathieu l'évoqué a fini par se convertir
à reculons l'économie de marché la
france insoumise et chercher d'autres
textes théoriques ils ne reconnaissent
pas vraiment le capitalisme de libre
échange avec le capital ils sont pour la
rupture est que le capital rappelle que
dans l'accord et à y avait des
discussions avec le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste et fois senteurs et il
présente la retraite à 60 ans il ya
longtemps que le parti socialiste en a
fait son deuil en sachant que ça n'aide
pas finançable sérieux économiquement et
je dirais même plus profondément que ça
le parti socialiste est là on revient à
10 920 au congrès tour et la fameuse
adresse de blum mes chers camarades nous
allons garder la vieille maison c'est
que le parti socialiste fondamentalement
est un parti institutionnel démocratique
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre électoral la
france un soumise à une relation
beaucoup plus élastique à la démocratie
en gros ils sont pour les élections
quand illégal mais pas tellement quand
ils les perde
je vous rappelle que depuis cinq ans a
noté 11 fois où jean luc blachon appeler
à l'insurrection mois insurrection ces
grains mots qui a un sens je vous
rappelle que lian que hier encore un
député de la france insoumise appelé à
chasser emmanuel macron il a été le 24
avril d'hier un député soumis appelé à
chasser à coups de bâtons emmanuel
macron donc on est on est quand même
dans une relation un tout petit peu
compliqué à la démocratie électorale est
sûre donc cet accord de mon point de vue
je pense que les socialistes s'ils l'ont
avalisé en dix jours si l'on fait un
virage stratégique aussi énorme en dix
jours c'est pas seulement parce que ils
étaient dans leur être nécessité et à
votre bon coeur mais c'est aussi parce
qu'au fond je pense qu'ils se disent ça
n'a pas grande importance parce que
toute façon on est à peu près sûr de
perdre et ce but coup ça me rappelle une
anecdote six prime de réaliser que deux
duos de mon grand tu as raison j'ai vécu
des circonstances comme un peu comme ça
en 2000 en
c'est dominique strauss kahn qui rédige
le programme de
de la gauche qui va gagner oui le sait
pas encore mais c'est paris 35 et c'est
lui c'est une invention de strauss kahn
je dessine je déjeune avec lui en tête à
tête et je lis les 35 heures sont pas
vraiment 35 heures payées 39 ou 40 j'ai
plus trop dans un monde hyper
concurrentiel du proc économie française
peut hélas il me répond non évidemment
pas évidemment pas mais ça n'a aucune
importance parce que toute façon on est
sûr de perdre quand on réalise un
programme électoral il faut toujours
envisager l'hypothèse qu'on puisse
gagner oui c'était de très bonnes
anecdotes jusqu'au alors évidemment il
ya on l'a un peu évoquée mais il ya la
réaction de nombreux poids lourds du
parti
socialiste on dit plus les éléphants
mais on pourrait pour qui cet accord est
inacceptable écouté par exemple le maire
du mans stéphane le foll c'était ce
matin sur france 2
sa fin du parti socialiste elle qu'il a
existé jusqu'ici c'est la fin aussi
d'une idée socialiste du socialisme
français ont parlé du front populaire il
n'ya pas longtemps faux couple hier
c'était d'abord léon blum c'était le
congrès de tours donc hier
stéphane le foll qui se dit prêt à
prendre la tête de liste dissidente avec
tous les socialistes qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans cette dans cet
accord nathalie mort et j'ai envie de
dire avec avec l argent pour quel
résultat
c'est même pas le problème je pense que
les dissidents enfin je le pense très
sincèrement n'ont qu'une chance
justement parce que jean daniel le
disais tout à l'heure il ya une terre un
tel désir des gens de gauche de voir
l'unité
je ne suis pas totalement certaine que
les gens qui rentreront en dissidence
par rapport à cet accord quoi qu'on en
pense est une chance de gagner il ya un
sondage est là qui dit 80% des
sympathisants de gauche 71% des
sympathisants ps qui souhaite un accord
même sans compter que ceux qui ne sont
pas pour cet accord ils sont déjà à la
république en marche en tous les cas en
soutien du président élu mais pas tous
ont failli à vous poser la question des
éléphants peut se demander aussi un peu
ce qu'ils ont fait depuis cinq ans parce
que beaucoup se sont mis à l'écart donc
maintenant ils viennent bas rires parce
qu'ils sont pas contents
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait pendant cinq
ans bien après tout disait oui le parti
de blue le parti de mitterrand on aurait
pu dire une partie de jospin aujourd'hui
le ps est le parti de qui
je trouve que l'essayer c'est très
intéressant de regarder qui négocie les
trois personnes qui sont sans leur faire
injure inconnu des français dont un qui
n'est pas élu laurent boix m n'a pas de
mandat un conseiller régional et leader
des défendeurs annoncé qu'un qui est
dans l'air et c'est laurent baumel qui
rédigeaient les livres et les discours
de dominique strauss kahn mais qui est
devenu ensuite fondeur un conseiller
régional de loire-atlantique christophe
clergeau et puis un conseiller
départemental de la drôme pierre jouve
est
encore une fois sans leur faire injure
qui se plaint m était candidat main
cronista en 2017 et qui est porte parole
du parti socialiste mais qui sait c'est
pas des poids lourds c'est pas des
éléphants c'est sûr qu'il n'entraîne pas
un courant de pensée au parti socialiste
derrière eux donc que cueillait des des
membres du parti socialiste qui ne se
sentent pas représentés ou qui ne se
sentent pas qu'ils ne leur semble pas
une légitimité même s'ils ont une
légitimité parce que il ya eu un vote
pour donner à cette délégation a la
légitimité pour aller négocier avec la
france en 2001 ils sont pas les deux de
leur propre volonté de leurs preneurs
mais je trouve que voilà il ya ccca
cette image là à la fois les éléphants
ils ont été absents ils ont rien fait
bernard cazeneuve à faire un texte que
je trouve assez remarquable de clarté
après on est d'accord pas d'accord mais
c'est très clair et pas de mauvais jeux
de mots il n'a pas le faire comme les
autres il avait une un texte assez très
très clairière mais qu'est ce qu'il a
fait depuis cinq ans et il aurait pu y
aller à la présidentielle et il aurait
pu se mobiliser ils auraient pu investir
un courant il aurait pu prendre le parti
socialiste le truc c'est que plus
personne n'en voulait en revenant ils
ont quand même un peu beau jeu de crier
qu'on le défigure qu'on le déteste quand
même c'était intéressant lucas est
intéressant en effet parce que c'était
un nationaux à plusieurs reprises il a
été approché bien sûr qu'il a été
sollicité pour devenir en full leader
d'associer démocratie qui se cherchait
un maître d'oeuvre et il s'est très vite
et toujours demi sur leur coût de
reculoir en disant au fond c'est ces
gens ne m'aiment pas ils me veulent pas
donc j'y vais pas il ya eu il ya encore
quelques mois le laisse poids pour
certain qu'il soit candidat à la
présidentielle quand on a vu que hidalgo
ça marchait pas il ya des gens qui ont
essayé de pousser un plan b qui était un
plan cazeneuve et du même incident n'a
pas voulu se mouiller ce qui est assez
frappant pour rebondir sur ce qu'ils
disent et matthieu croissandeau c'est
que il y avait plus de députés ps et que
député français soumise à l'assemblée
nationale et que si vous demandez aux
français ce qu'ils ont retenu de cette
dernière english nature évidemment ce
qu'ils ont retenu de la part des députés
socialistes ils sont bien en peine de
pouvoir me dire il faut une prise de
position soit une proposition complète
effectuée soit même un contre budget
alors même qu y en a eu en fait et qui
ont été émis à de la part du parti
socialiste ou une un moment où il y
aurait pu avoir un côté tonitruante de
la part des socialistes qui a qui aurait
pu figer le débat et allant même que les
les insoumis et et soumettront pas deux
fois moins nombreux à l'international là
vous avez foultitude de moments forts
qui ont été évoqués de la part de nos
compatriotes que ce soit sur la question
des appels que ce soit sur la question
en fait de la politique d' emmanuel
macron à la politique internationale
c'est donc en fait il ya eu aussi cette
fonction tribunitienne à laquelle la
gauche comme traditionnellement
adapté par droite et qui en fait au
final n'a pas trouvé derrière le parti
socialiste après 52 de deux mandats de
manuel mâcon alors jean venu je vais
rester avec vous pour voir cette
projection vous avez interrogé les
français sondage et puis ça va donc ces
sondages d'intention de votre part par
partie et vous avez notamment réalisé
cette projection de l'assemblée
nationale à l'issue des législatives
alors on va regarder l'hypothèse sans
alliance on l'appelle comme ça ou offre
détails et on voit une majorité absolue
pour la république en marche si on
regarde à gauche
le parti communiste entre 5 et 10 sièges
la france insoumise entre 25 et 45 le
parti socialiste de 20 à 40 et europe
ecologie les verts entre 15,5 et puis à
droite jusqu'à au mieux 65 sièges pour
les républicains et le rassemblement
national
jusqu'à 100 sièges au mieux on regarde
uniquement sur cette projection la alors
peut-être une petite question de
pédagogie pour commencer parce que je
vais être honnête avec vous depuis une
dizaine de jours où on avait montré
votre première connexion lendemain delà
de la victoire d'emmanuel bacon et elle
a été pas mal critiquée par vos
confrères en disant mais comment il fait
pour arriver à une projection d'une
salle va alors déjà un dans la note
qu'il a rédigée en même temps d'y
prononcer de données avec prudence voire
une prochaine données avec prudence pour
plusieurs raisons 1 on connaît pas
encore le prix mini 2 on n'a pas encore
les accords programmatiques entre les
différentes formations politiques
étroits on connaît pas encore les
candidats en circonscription aux confins
exercice qui est un exercice très
théorique on imagine que vous avez dans
toutes les circonscriptions dont les 577
circonscriptions
toutes les offres politiques qui sont
présentes et comment ça pourrait se
manifester donc on demande aux électeurs
comment s comportera premier tour ou au
deuxième tour on va très vite voir se
décanter notamment parce qu'on aura
connaissance des candidats dans les
circonscriptions également des accords
entre les différentes formations
politiques une des questions qui se pose
c'est est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on a des
électeurs qui déclare qu'il souhaite
donner la majorité au président de la
république et quand on regarde l'analyse
que soit l'analyse en pourcentage
d'intentions de vote dans le cas du
premier tour dans le cas des
configurations de second tour est la
meilleure nous ça peut se projeter
issus des traditions ses différentes
configurations que à l'heure actuelle
même si les français c'est pas forcément
exactement ce qu'ils souhaitent semble
dire on va donner une majorité au
président n'a appliqué on aurait tous en
alliance avec horse avec ou sans
alliance ou globalement en fait on est
face à des électeurs notamment de ceux
qui ont voté pour aimer le marron qui
pour une partie importante d'entre eux
déclarent au premier tour des élections
aux assises comme deuxième tour des
élections initiative jeu susceptible de
faire de produire cette situation-là de
d'une reproduction d'un comportement
électoral qu'on a pu voir au cours de
l'élection nourrit un ciel où vous on a
même que le facteur sonne deux fois
quoique le 2022 va être en gros à peu
près le remake de 2007 c'est à dire ce
que je dis c'est qu'il ya une semaine et
demie après le deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle le facteur est
en train de sonner deux fois mais ce que
je dis également ce qu'on a pas de
premier ministre ça a changé
fondamentalement la donne au cours de la
dernière élection de législatives et
l'arrivée d'edouard philippe a changé
nettement ya renforcé le camp de la
réplique en marche est ce que jeudi
également c'est que quand on aura
l'offre politique réelle on pourra y
voir beaucoup plus clair parce que c'est
pas la même chose de dire vous voter
pour un candidat soutenu en gros par la
france assume isu parti socialiste ou
lorsqu'on aura des personnalités qui
seront un peu plus connu dans les
différents territoires alors et emmanuel
macron dans tout ça pendant ce temps il
prend son temps c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent à l'issue du conseil des
ministres écoutez
il ya l'investiture du président de la
république pour son second mandat qui
aura lieu ce samedi conformément à ce
qui était annoncé par la présidence de
la république et il y a le premier
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron qui
s'achève le 13 mai à minuit est ce que
je peux vous dire ce que je sais c'est
que le gouvernement castex ira au bout
de ce premier quinquennat emmanuel
macron jean castex qui restent donc en
pause jusqu'au 13 mai mathieu vous êtes
surpris par la gestion du tempo du
calendrier par le présent de la publier
parce que c'est pas tout se faire élire
mais il faut gouverner maman et
du moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il
ya comme un petit peu un retard à
l'allumage alors je sais que les plus
fins stratèges de la république en
marche passent leur temps à expliquer
que dans cette attente pour ce pas dire
selon vide c'est voulu c'est calculé
c'est super malin en fait pourquoi parce
que le président est le maître des
horloges que personne ne lui impose son
calendrier et puis que la nomination de
gouvernement et saturent à tel point
l'espace médiatique que l'opposition
sera réduite au silence et que c'est
encore mieux si c'est près des
législatives bref voilà ce qu'on entend
du côté de l'exécutif en attendant
qu'est ce qui se passe bien c'est qu'on
ne parle essentiellement que les autres
c'est-à-dire de l'opposant numéro un
jean luc mélenchon de l'union de la
gauche pour dire du bien pour dire du
mal mais on ne parle que de ça et la
majorité a bien du mal à se mettre en
branle les ministres et les caciques de
la macro ni ils se terrent ils se
taisent de peur de commettre une
boulette qui compromettrait leur avenir
pour gouvernement par exemple ils sont
tous un préavis les partants les partis
qui composaient la soi-disante maison
commune de la majorité il se mettra et
peinent à se mettre d'accord sur le
partage des circonscriptions et puis le
président pen lui a trouvé un ou plutôt
une locataire pour matignon en tout cas
il semble peiner au point que on entend
même des refus maintenant qu'ils sont
rendus publics dans la presse ce qui est
assez inédit et ce qui facilite ce qui
ne facilitera pas la tâche il a des
gîtes imiter de l'heureuse ou de
l'heureuse élue alors comment le
président réélu peut reprendre
l'initiative en politique comme à table
on n'est jamais mieux servi que par soi
même donc du coup emmanuel macron ci
mais ça commence aujourd'hui par la
sortie d'une série vidéo sur youtube
retraçant la saga de la saga pardon
présidentiel regarder
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'à mieux pensée ouvert
parfait
voilà prêt pour mener le combat
là aucune série façon série télévisée
pour reprendre la parole sans rien dire
puisque en fait tout bien sûr deux
précédents cas qu'est la sas et puis
viendra samedi le sacre avec
l'investiture d'un président qui se
passe les pouvoirs à lui-même le colis
de la légion d'honneur les coups de
canon ça c'est pour le récit comme
disent les communicants après il ya la
politique avec la nomination d'un
premier ministre et dans la foulée de
son gouvernement et va y avoir de la
casse a déjà prévenu l'entourage du
président l'objectif est de présenter
quand même une équipe renouvelée avec
des symboles pour montrer que le
président a entendu le message des
français aux bandes sa réélection donc
les nouveaux visages des hommes et des
femmes de gauche peut-être plus écolo et
puis politique toujours il ya la
question des investitures aux
législatives dont on nous dit qu'elles
sont supervisés valider une à une depuis
le bureau présidentiel l'objectif c'est
de ramener tous les partis et les micro
partis qui composent la majorité sous
une bannière commune histoire de faire
régner l'ordre dans les rangs et puis
enfin pour lui il faut passer de la
parole aux actes désormais c'est à dire
mettre en oeuvre son programme une fois
que le gouvernement sera nommé bien
entendu donc ça faudra encore attendre
un peu plus d'une semaine avec un
objectif donné des gages vite très vite
en vue des législatives avec des mesures
sur le pouvoir d'achat le lancement du
chantier sur la santé sur les réformes
de l'éducation ça c'est ce qu'il a
annoncé est une inconnue la retraite qui
était un curseur de droite un marqueur
de droite de la présidentielle qui est
devenu un cas était un peu raboté dans
l'entre-deux-tours il faut bien l'avouer
qui est devenu aujourd'hui l'argument
phare symbole
de l'opposition que ce soit du côté de
jean-luc mélenchon et de marine le pen
donc est ce que mme emmanuel macron
voudra en refaire un totem ou est-ce que
ça va devenir un tabou c'est toute la
question nathalie mort et ça veut dire
que il va falloir encore attendre une
bonne semaine avant que la campagne
législative commence vraiment
éventuellement comment sur le fond des
propositions n'ai pas l'impression
qu'elle a déjà commencé là quand on
parle pas beaucoup de programmes les
programmes finalement c'est pas si
j'allais dire que c'est pas si important
évidemment que si c'est important parce
que ça on a vu qu'il ya une bataille
entre elf qui est le ps aujourd'hui mais
la legge accompagne des législatives sur
le terrain je vous assure qu'elle a
commencé à les voir à vénissieux là où
la france assume insoumise veut investir
face à la maire pc de vénissieux vous
allez voir si elle n'a pas commencé par
tout autour localement sur le terrain je
vous assure que les députés sortants
sont sur le terrain notamment et l'air
pour sauver leur peau voilà comment
c'est vraiment jean daniel lévy havas
gagné plutôt à droite s'est tu quand
cette campagne législative quand même
parce que on a on le disait à la
majorité est quand même tout le pays le
cailly penche à droite où il fait le
pays électoralement mais penche à droite
idéologiquement c'est un peu plus
compliqué parce qu'en fait il ya
également des thématiques sur les
services publics la place de l'état la
notion de solidarité qui votent penche à
droite bien sûr ceux qui votent penche à
droite et ceux qui sont déplacés au
cours de la dernière élection
provinciale ont plutôt penché à droite
ou alors ont voté quand il était au
centre gauche en faveur d' emmanuel
macron plus que ce que certains laisser
laissé entrevoir quoi qu'il en soit la
nomination du premier va vraiment
permettre de donner l'impulsion complète
de ce que peut être la campagne
électorale si j'ai bien compris la
logique finalement le premier ministre
et celui qui est sensé mais la bataille
pour les législatives même si a priori
il y aura quand même manuel macron qui
sera déjà cela il sera autour de lui que
ça que ça se singularisera vraiment
enfin je pense qu'on a mésestimé le rôle
qu'avait joué l'arrivée des noirs film
de bruno le maire de gérald darmanin au
cours du dernier quinquennat et doit
finit pas dit quelque chose qui n'avait
jamais été dit sur le perron de matignon
il avait dit je suis droite et en disant
ça on avait des électeurs qui pensait
clairement voté pour un candidat l air
qu on dira qu'on n'a pas compris en fait
on l'a gagné et donc qui ont changé leur
comportement électoral et qui n'ont pas
voté pour le candidat la réplique en
marche qui ne connaissait pas enfin pour
le cognac l'air mais pour le candidat
réplique en marche quand même il ne
connaissait pas tant et si bien que
quand on interroge ses électeurs en 2007
à l'audience mais au fait sur quel
programme politique vous avez voté
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé ils ont dit
nous avons voulu donner majorité au
président de la clique donc il n'est pas
forcément ce contenu politique autour
d'un programme qui est il n'est pas
forcément clairement identifié la part
des électeurs alors on va terminer ce
débat en se posant une question grâce à
alexandre tout ça on va voir là la
réponse bon soit alexandre que vous
faire les ministres qui ont donc
quelques jours de rab on l'a bien
compris dans ces législatives c'est bien
ce soir vous a préparé une carte de
france pour voir où les ministres
pourraient se présenter aux législatives
est d'abord il y a les ministres qui
partent à la conquête d'un siège de
député est celui qui sera observée de
près c'est jean michel blanquer le
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
devrait se présenter dans le loiret au
centre du pays le ministre de
l'éducation qui n'est pas du tout assuré
de rester au gouvernement
et il veut avoir un ancrage local car il
n'a jamais été élu autre ministre qui
souhaite remporter sa première élection
c'est eric dupond moretti
le garde des sceaux il est pressenti
pour être candidat dans le département
du nord dans une circonscription a gagné
en 2010 cette part à la république en
marche dans le département voisin du pas
de calais c'est la miss de l'industrie
agnès pannier rue nash et qui devrait
être candidate en normandie elisabeth
bornes dont le nom circule pour le poste
de premier ministre eh bien elle devrait
se présenter dans les partenaires du
calvados et puis sophie cluzel en haute
savoie se récuser de la ministre en
charge des personnes en situation de
handicap du côté de la région parisienne
ce serait clément bonne le secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes qui va
se lancer à paris et puis la ministre du
logement emmanuelle wargon dans le
département du val de marne alors ça
c'était pour les ministres en conquête
ya aussi ceux qui se représentent oui
plusieurs ministres vont tenter de
conserver leur siège à l'assemblée
nationale comme bruno le maire en
normandie dans son département de l'eure
pour olivier ferrand le ministre de la
santé est élu député de l'isère en 2017
et bien la bataille s'annonce compliquée
car dans sa circonscription qui prend
une partie de la ville de grenoble eh
bien allez voie de gauche additionner
ont récolté 41 % des voix au premier
tour de la présidentielle donc ce n'est
pas gagné pour olivier ferrand et puis
d'autres ministres veulent conserver
leur siège un petit peu plus au sud de
l'isère dans les hautes-alpes joël
giraud vise un cinquième mandat alès
c'est la secrétaire d'état bérengère à
bâle en charge de la biodiversité qui va
se présenter en haute-marne tout comme
laurent kg et rachesky dans le nord
brigitte bourguignon dans le pas de
calais et puis il ya les ministres modem
aussi qui veulent rempiler dans le loir
et cher c'est marc fesneau le ministre
en charge des relations avec le
parlement qui devrait se représenter en
loire-atlantique sahara et railleries ou
plus au sud dans les landes geneviève
darrieussecq et on finit à part un
dernier détour dans la région parisienne
en ile-de-france avec des ministres qui
souhaitent conserver leur siège olivier
grégoire à paris également gabriel attal
le porte parole du gouvernement qui est
bien un siège de député dans les
hauts-de-seine il avait conquis une
circonscription à la droite en 2017 et
maintenant cette circonscription elle
est vraiment macro nist et puis plus au
sud de l'île de france d'ouest en est on
peut citer à nadia et dans les yvelines
à milou montchalin dans l'essonne et
puis franck riester en seine et marne
franck restèrent le ministre du commerce
extérieur il certains en a terminé avec
l'ue ont décidé de ne pas se représenter
et oui c'est le cas de la ministre
marlène schiappa alors ça peut paraître
un peu surprenant mais elle annoncé
qu'elle ne se représenterait pas aux
élections législatives sont prêts et
bien préciser les raisons de son refus
même décision pour jean-baptiste
djebbari le ministre en charge des
transports cedrico en charge du
numérique adrien taquet le secrétaire
d'état à la protection de l'enfance et
on termine avec le premier d'entre eux
jean castex alors jean castex ne devrait
pas se présenter aux législatives mais
il est pressenti pour être candidat aux
prochaines sénatoriales en 2023
d'ailleurs son grand père marc castex a
été sénateur du gers pendant neuf ans ça
peut peut-être lui donner des idées
merci beaucoup merci alexandre poussard
et merci à tous merci d'avoir participé
à ce débat c'était passionnant à bientôt
sur sur public sénat